siccome i capelli fanno cagare facciamo
che io utilizzo questo durante il video
se mi vedo i capelli che non mi vanno
bene faccio così questo perché tu mi hai
fatto così quindi si assumi la
responsabilità delle colpe 77 si
pettinari buongiorno ragazze che la
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono suo figlio oggi sempre che
stiamo facendo questo video si completa
esatto allora volevo fare un altro video
per il mio compleanno
vi do un po più elaborato e figo però
uscirà più avanti perché vista la
situazione non posso farlo e allora ho
detto se e quando io vivevo qui c'era
questo scatolone gigante bianco che
questo questo scatolone che non ho mai
capito e bradley che disco sesta scatola
tra l'altro quelle scatole che nascono
nelle case ma non si sa come ci sono
finite che pieno di foto di me da
bambino e oggi visto che questo caso
sono completamente inedite facciamo una
reaction almè di 25 anni fa
ok ci ha 25 anni fa più o meno in realtà
era ero piccolo ma c'è una foto normale
di quando c'è un po di quito non so
perché i ragazzi non mi divertivo quando
lo piccolo e non mi piaceva fare lo
youtuber solo che non esisteva youtube
capito quindi ero preso male dalla vita
ma qui perché mi avevi fatto i capelli
così corti facevo cagare quei capelli
corti che era così felice ero
felicissimo e aver ricevuto questo
bellissimo regalo una fottutissima
maglia pro grazie per rendere sempre
soddisfazione ed è perché non a persona
gentile
quando ci caliamo sopra ma poi ma magari
non ammette vine anni ma quindi nella
soddisfazione si bella ma stavo marcando
il territorio questa era per marcare il
territorio ragazzi giusto così
ami questa tabella aspetta queste
perdevi fi beaufort questa bellissima
anche negli ultim si no pixo o al mons
ap c'è mail o fra equa festa questa
bellissima perché mia mamma dovete
sapere che sta che tu compravi i numeri
insomma di riviste chi come si chiamano
quelle robe la quindi gossip e vedevi
camionisti vestiti così allora cosa
dicevi beh siamo mio figlio come un
camionista con la canotta olive riguarda
il berretto da che guarda questo è
questo il berretto da camionista questo
è un bel questa è la canotta da
camionista e questi sono i jeans da
camilo tutto da camionista l'unica cosa
che posso notare è la mia protuberanza
di culo che ho anche attualmente ma ci
ritengono che sensi si è ormai non so
più cosa dire
io faccio solo vedere le può però
comunque eravate bravi a fotografarmi
solo in queste situazioni grazie non ci
sono foto normali io sto cercando una
foto normale non c'è questa
mamma questa sì questo bambino che era
riconosciuto sulla spiaggia a quello che
si chiamava giacomo giacomo sai perché
me lo ricordo perché lo chiamavo giacomo
giacomo pokémon già con shell chissà
dov'è finito giacomo giacomo ciao ancora
un sacco di giocatori di bastardo della
madonna
mamma mia ma veramente certo il parto ma
come possibile insieme per quello che si
è così bello ma vorrei capelli i capelli
tu guarda i capelli come ce li hai fatti
bene e io che cosa così spiegarmi che
cosa c'è nella vita del problema a
questo me lo ricordo questo qua
era un uomo lover di poi era una specie
di gonfiabile bellissimo era bellissimo
treno un gonfiabile che aveva tutto è
cosa da boxe non dovevi adesso vi giuro
se ce l'avessi adesso vi ci farei video
va dentro veramente figo pesare una foto
che questa foto mi piace molto è una
foto con denis mi piace tanto perché se
notate denise che la mia amica a lei
manca un dente invece io i denti davanti
ce li ho fin troppo quindi c'è a chi
tutto e chi niente proprio bellissimo
nave ma lei era più piccola di due anni
in capito ma perché avevo degli antoni
che sembra voti invitarne che bale loeb
rete ecco le bretelle sai che non ci
sono ancora
ma c'e dai quasi prima di vedere come mi
stanno adesso per una volta le mettevo
fiero non ci credo ma non ci credo lei
trovate subito bellissimo presente
aspettavo di adesso mi ricordo
me lo ricordo ma ricordo perché non
ammettevano che ti ricordi malamente o
così dovrebbe arrivarne fino dove fino
al culo non mi arriverà mai
qua qua invece la cosa bellissima e che
io andavo ti ricordi che andava pazzo
per le giraffe e anche per il colore
rosa
no questo no mettiamo
non è vero ma non è vero recitò andava
pazzo per le giraffe tant'è vero che
quando andavo all'asilo perché andavo
all'asilo qua da titoli che il mio
simbolo era fuggo la giraffa ma la
materia ad oggi non so come mai queste
giraffe quando scopri che sei su un
canale da 5 milioni e mezzo di iscritti
non so infatti perché hai fatto di altri
nomi dico guarda che sorriso
forzatissimo che avevo la serietà mi
aveva appena detto sorridi e io ho fatto
così uguale bellissimo lo ricordi quando
facevo gli anni io piangevo sempre ma io
lo so perché
ero timido che c'entra capito mi
guardavano tutti anche adesso sono così
mi guardavano in vigore nei sette piango
stupido guardano miliardi il costo
compleanno non piangerei perché siamo in
tre meravigliose e miley cyrus ha fatto
successo già nel 95 ma di serie c su
questa sono capitate uguale e fammi
vedere cosa c era in quella torta mamma
poi non ce le tantissime perchè abbiamo
i video non ho certo prova belle foto i
video li avevo già commentati però le
foto non l'avevo ancora fatto vedere
andate a vedere i video sono avete visti
perché c'è roba incredibile fa vj da
piccolo braga per chi non li ha mai
visti quelle sono perle che ogni tanto
riguardo anche io sul canale perché è
incredibile bella western ferma qua ecco
questa funzione delle più belle che
abbiamo
no questo no femmine fiction rovinate da
gismondo a sinistra questa penso che si
commenti da sola non dico neanche alle
volte è meglio non dire niente ma qual è
la mia faccia ti prego lei il mio primo
rolex
mai nessun orologio in italiano perché
facevo le storie su instagram io dietro
tutta tutta in posa io facevo le storie
su instagram a quando non esisteva
instagram era la tua tipa sembra un cono
gelato mi tuffo verso i soldi con un
doppio carpiato bella no questi sono i
testi de andrè né sentito però comunque
nelle foto in spiaggia devo dire che
fotogenico lo sono abbastanza questo è
perché io in spiaggia ancora adesso
effettivamente vesco sempre così nelle
foto quindi non mi faccio foto in
spiaggia però neanche normali mele
dovrei fare questo ma c'è una foto
normale di dove io sono tranquillo senza
fare cose stupide non esiste o questa è
carina
nel dopoguerra ma carina le feste di
compleanno qua nel mio palazzo erano
sempre meravigliose perché io non avevo
amici ero solo amiche perché
vedete anche dalla torta di magica
doremi io non non c'erano ragazzi nel
bambini nel solo bambine
quindi io tra una guerra e l'altra
andavo a giocare con i colleghi winx
frega se tutto mi fa passato si poeta
devo salutare possiamo salutare corini
di andate a cagare
ragazzi questa è la è un video strano in
realtà perché volevo fare una cosa un po
più e motional però purtroppo la
situazione non lo permette ma la faremo
niente sono stati 25 anni migliori della
mia vita e vi ringrazio per aver fatto
parte ringrazio la mia mamma per avermi
fatto e basta
pesano non sarei qua pensa se non mi
avessi fatto a quest'ora ci sarebbero su
youtube 3 miliardi di visualizzazioni in
meno
mi vorrei ci sono quindi meno male però
che questo video vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio la mia mamma per aver
partecipato questo video siamo tutti e
due molto timidi quindi l'incredibile la
compilation del fringe e uno speciale un
po strano non sono molto contento di
averlo fatto
rimando un bacino ci vediamo tra 25 anni
facciamo specie di 50 vabbè ci diamo a
un prossimo video senza bretelle queste
mele porto comunque mi apre le mie
bretelle
[Musica]